good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on strategy
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend friday friday getting
down on saturday
hello everyone happy friday or should we
say happy stride from jackson claude and
raz and stress the four of us are here
to kick off the weekend
with just like a gorgeous energy the
gang's all here i actually feel as
though we need to start you know giving
credit to the streis brothers like this
is a four-person podcast yeah and we
need four microphones we need four
microphones we need everyone on the
artwork we need new artwork but in due
time yeah
uh i was just thinking because i
realized it was friday but i didn't have
that typical feeling of like yes it's
friday like we made it because this week
has just been so pleasant because you're
here and every day is just like not as
strenuous
days before i was just going to say that
like i'm like not even like excited that
it's friday because that means like i'm
leaving on sunday like that means right
the final part the final installment of
my trip here is coming and
honestly like i'm not down and i'm
wondering if even when you're gone i'm
just like podcasting
from home
if fridays are gonna hit the same as
they used to because i'm just leading a
more peaceful life i think eventually
like when you get into like a when you
really actually live here like you like
for sure live here yeah the daily grind
you'll get back to like that week
everyone you always say the great
equalizer is the week so even people who
live in the suburbs you know yeah that's
true plus on the weekends they do get to
sleep in and that's
next level even if everything else about
the day is pretty much the same
it's always going to be my personal
favorite pastime speaking of sleeping in
i have to tell you i'm two days in a row
of having full blackout sleep here like
you know the nights where you just are
uninterrupted like you close your eyes
and you open them and then it's your
alarm like it's so i barely get like
rarely get it at home i'm here two
nights in a row
i think it has a lot to do with the
peaceful energy you've cultivated but
also a lot to do with the fact that on
wednesday night i got two hours of sleep
i think it's more so the first one
because sometimes when you even though
you got two hours of sleep like it
doesn't guarantee that the next night
you're gonna sleep really good like you
could be in a really bad pattern
so true but we're breaking the cycle we
are breaking it ends with us like we're
bringing the cycle um so i just wanted
to say like kudos to you ben is loving
the bed like he would and he's so
you think i'm particular and difficult
to host ben could find fault in like a
michelin star restaurant and he has like
yeah he
has a really hard time giving
compliments he's extremely particular um
and he's made multiple comments without
even me prodding like how great is this
bed he wakes up like oh this bed and
he's i can't really stress like he's
[ __ ] judgmental not me [ __ ] well i'm
so glad and what about theo he's really
like he's ebert and roper he's the
critic that you want to please theo's
really like a
love who you're with love where you are
kind of guy like i wish i had that kind
of spirit he's very much happy with what
he's given he doesn't know luxury from
standard he's
really kind of um reached a level of
like equilibrium and peace with the
world which is what we should all be
striving for i'm super far from that um
so he could be happy anywhere so no
offense like his seal means nothing i
think he's extra happy here because not
only does he have everything that he
needs he has his cousins yeah and he has
his auntie
and i feel like he's having a good time
even though he's like that grumpy old
man walking around saying what are you
kids up to he's squidward yes and bruno
and magnolia are patrick and spongebob
bruno is spongebob there's never been a
better comparison magnolia is patrick
it is
like a combo of squidward and mr krabs
because he's like in charge but he's
also like a boring old man yeah he he
gives squidward sometimes and
he's still even squidward was having a
good time that's how you know [ __ ] is
rocking when squidward is smiling
we've got what we should have named them
imagine squidward's like kind of a cute
name actually yeah well that's an
interesting thing when we do meet and
greet so many people bring their dogs
and it's so interesting to see what
people name their dogs yeah what did
that what was the name that we were like
was it popcorn no there was snoring it
was so many snorkel thank you there were
so many dogs at the meet and greet and
i'm always just interested to see what
people name their dogs yeah i had such a
bad dream about bryce i know don't worry
do you want to talk it was so realistic
and in the dream i do this thing in my
dreams where i'm like this is probably a
dream like let's get out yeah let's go
to the next one
and sometimes i'm in such a deep sleep i
can't get out of it i'm like let me out
it's mental warfare i just have to trust
the process and know that i will wake up
and bryce will be right there and know
that you'll grow where you're planted
and where you're planted yes
i hope you will i hope you will i'm
sorry that you've been through that i've
been through that
many times in many nights and there's
really nothing
nothing that can prepare you for like a
dream that's so reality that is your
worst fears come to life you know my
angel bryce i know he didn't deserve
that no and you know in the dream whose
fault it was hermes it was no it was
mine for shopping at armies yeah
jackie's like dreaming of purchasing
birkins in the store
and bryce gets like taking a really long
time you know when you go shopping at
like a really nice store and you're like
i'm gonna buy this bag like please take
my money and then it's like you sit
there for 30 minutes while they package
it up it's like i'm trying to give you
my money yeah no i think they like
luxury shopping they try and make it
like an experience they offer you [ __ ]
you want to get the [ __ ] out of there a
good experience is getting back to my
bed so don't even make me sit on this
tiny little hard couch for when you like
bring out a receipt on a silver tray
like if you're waiting for the tray
because you guys only have one and
someone else is using it like just bring
me the recipe crumple the receipt up and
put it in the bag like i just want to go
i emailed it to me i found what i'm
looking for so that's what was happening
in my dream i was buying a birkin and it
was taking like 45 minutes to get it and
i was just like what am i doing you know
you're sick like that's what you dream
of buying perkins like you're mentally
ill well there was other things going on
too for sure there were in dreams you
know things don't really make sense so
it wasn't like
buying a birkin outright there was other
things happening too maybe the
let's try and extrapolate like a message
from the dream you're buying a bird and
it's taking too long you're like so busy
that you forget to take care of your dog
and your dog runs out in the street and
hospital god forbid get hit by a car
what does that say
where are your priorities maybe it's a
it's a statement no i think it was like
a fear and like a warning not that i
think my priorities are out of order
currently but there's a lot going on
don't let them get out of order
yeah or
don't let your love for bryce like slip
through the cracks like now you have a
full-blown child my love for bryce
slipped through the cracks look what
could happen even though it literally
has not like my love for bryce is just
sort of seeing him as a brother a cousin
a boyfriend a son
it's one of the most beautiful things
i've witnessed yeah so i don't really
know what the message was because i
couldn't love this boy more i couldn't
give him like more love and attention no
it's true like i thought your like
priorities would definitely shift a
little bit away from rice when you had a
child which is extremely normal um they
have not yeah yeah waivers have included
everything
everything you're larping just as much
with bryce as you do with he goes in the
stroller on the bottom he likes it there
that's so cute he was chilling hard
that's like usually when we go for walks
he cries if we're going for like a
family walk he's just like this is not i
don't know what this means you do not
feel safe yeah i don't feel safe i feel
unsure so we put him in the bottom of
the stroller where you put like your
stroller tings and he loved it
sickening so yeah
i'm sorry well while you were you know
dreaming i was at a wedding last night
which was just great for me
scheduling-wise to be here be able to
podcast go to a wedding
i looked gorgeous actually felt bad like
you know stunting stunting on the bride
and i'm kidding she looked so pretty um
i'm just tired weddings are so much work
like on your feet on your posture like
you always have to like
you could be slouching at a wedding no
ew so i'm my body feels heavy i need to
go for a swim nice i took my first bath
here last night that's crazy because
i've literally taken four baths
you inspired me really because every
night i'm like it's a long night i want
to take a bath but then i'm like it's a
long night i just want to shower and get
them i know so uh i did the bath and i
um it was nice i'm happy for you it was
nice it was also because i had a clog
did you shower before or after nope wow
look at you
i hate when people are like yeah i can
only take a bath if i shower before or
after am i good for you we don't care
yeah no if i'm like filthy then i'm not
gonna take a bath i'm not gonna do an
ironman and then take a bath you know
like
i'm just like i podcasted today like i
can i can take a bath without a shower
yes um well today's a big day let me
tell you why it's friday okay it's
friday yep yep also if you're a patreon
member you know we've been extremely
annoying and on my instagram teasing
about this new tnn new tnn new tnn big
announcements big things coming for tnn
we've been like particularly annoying
because we haven't given much no i know
um and there are a lot of things coming
up for tnn and one of them
is finally here so
we have a new show coming to tnn it is
our first
male show you know we're really we
empower female voices but
we're open to all
and we got so much great feedback from
my episode with josh peck people were
like please josh pack and we get so much
feedback when ben is on the podcast um
so they have decided to team up you know
they're really good friends that's how
we actually know josh and that's why he
came on the show um they're really good
friends they've like same funny like
jewish
chubby energy even though josh isn't
chubby anymore
um and they've decided to do a show
together it's called good guys because
they are just like two good guys
we were coming up with ideas and like
what's the vibe like you two are just
like a bunch of good guys and they're
like good guys it's really like my idea
um so it is live now the first episode
comes out on monday they're gonna be
dropping episodes every monday and you
can get it where you get the toast where
you get your podcasts anywhere amazon
stitcher spotify apple all the places
make sure to subscribe give a rating you
know help the charts um
i've listened to the first episode it's
so funny they're really like
they lead different lives obviously but
like at their core they're the same
person it's so funny and the episode was
so so funny and i have a hard time
listening to podcasts that like i'm not
on i can't lie um and it's really i like
i audibly cackled like four times
so funny it's so good it's such a great
idea they're gonna have so much fun
doing it and i feel like you guys are
going to love it yeah i think everyone
loved josh's episodes
so i think if you're a josh gurley if
you're a blunge girly you're going to
love the podcast so make sure to tune in
every monday and that's the big tnn
mogul news we you know what we were
looking for a friday segment what about
mogul news mogul news yeah not every
week is going to be a new tnn show but i
do feel as though we're doing something
mowgly at least once a week once a day
once a minute who are we kidding
so that's the big news of the day you
heard it here first tmz
no comment essentially
my comment is i'm so excited and i think
everyone is just going to
really enjoy and that's what we do here
at tnm we're just trying to get you
through the day we're just trying to
give you content that you're gonna enjoy
to make your day better go by quicker
get you to lunch time get you to five
o'clock yeah so the more we can put out
to get you to lunch
that's what we that's like why i wake up
in the morning i'm like the girlies need
content to hold them over
while pretending to work and i'm glad i
mean i'm so happy to be our own boss
love what we do but i'm glad that we had
that time in the corporate world to know
what it's like to watch that clock to
know what it's like to just crave
something to watch on youtube crave
something to listen to um it's it can be
a dark place
and then the commute like it like it
never ends it never ends you need so
much content to get through the day and
like that's why we do what we do that is
why we do what we
claudia ashrae tickets available at girl
no job.com tour oh that's good
jackie o raz and chasing
goosebumps
no we need to come up with a song for
tnn we can't force these things but just
we can't just keep that in the back of
your mind yeah
and that's our homework okay
um do we have a great show for them
today we do i picked the stories because
i was ready early jackie was you know
being a mom um
and they're not great i'm not gonna lie
to you um and i saw the most
i hate to like respond to comments but
like i said the most annoying comment
that like really grind my gears okay so
i guess there was like an episode this
week where we were like the stories are
met people like well if the stories are
meh why don't you just choose different
ones
like because the other ones were worse
yeah where
what's what suggest do it like it was
like like we're choosing bad stories
intentionally yeah no some days like
[ __ ] pops off other days not so much no
and like this weekend i just know we're
going to be it's like ben and jen
wedding bliss and like we're going to be
inundated this weekend i'm curious to
see who's going to be there i'm curious
to see who's going to officiate but i'm
not curious anymore because i chose the
story and then jackie took it out so um
which like who cares i really didn't do
you know who that was before you read
this story yes
um but the reason why i just want to
talk about it and i guess we are talking
about it now is because he's a podcaster
and that's just a win for podcasts like
that was really all i was gonna say i
agree but like everyone is a podcaster
now that like if you're not a podcaster
first i don't care that's like saying he
is a podcaster first okay fine fine and
his podcast is like enormous it's up
there with like armchair expert yeah but
that's like being like jason bateman
he's a podcaster that's a win for a
podcast okay well that's not j not j
shetty but i'm just saying like now that
everyone has a podcast no i know what
you're saying jay shetty is a
professional by trade podcaster okay
that's interesting because he's
definitely an actor but he has like a
top podcast too no i know for a really
long time conan
there are certain celebrities who toe
the line jack shepherd
podcaster these days yes but
because he was never that big of an act
like every real housewife has a podcast
so it's not just being like no there are
certain people who i definitely um i
think toe the line you just happen to
name literally all three of them dak
shepard conan and jason bateman um
i would still would say jason bateman is
an actor i would say
because jack shepard was really never
that big of a an actor he was mostly
like a professional husband his podcast
is so big like yeah he's a podcast good
for him you know yeah he really crossed
over he did but there are people who are
famous pod like us yeah we are
podcasters yes
100
but then there are famous people with
podcasts that do really well then they
start towing the line it's like are they
a podcaster or an actor you know yeah
it's always the actors get away from us
like can we have one thing can we have
one thing that was like that tim dillon
podcast where he was talking about how
everyone how everyone has a podcast and
soon we're just gonna have to like go
meet in the woods totally like the true
podcasters true
wait rpk real podcasters know
um but you know there's space for
everyone we welcome all to the community
well
we welcome all but i don't know if
there's space for everyone there is
because it's infinite you know it's not
like it's not like tv where there's only
so many slots and so many channels like
there could be infinite numbers of
podcasts but yes that's totally true but
podcasting as an art form definitely
weeds out the week i think everyone
thinks like i could talk for an hour
once a week because most podcasts are
weekly and then they start doing it and
there's so many podcasts that start and
never really finish
so that is validating in a sense like
it's not something everyone can do like
and it's not that easy agreed uh so many
people started podcasts especially in
coco did and it's interesting to see
who's still around yeah no i like to
watch the landscape shift i love to
watch the landscape shift i'm a
landscape watcher shifter yeah it's a
beautiful view
life's a climb but the view is great but
the landscape of podcasting is shifting
is shifting evermore
um okay i think we can dive in right i
think that we could dive into the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
sprit society end of summer we think not
at sprit society we're keeping the
season going strong through labor day
weekend celebrate the endless summer by
stocking up on all of the original
flavors grapefruit blood orange
pineapple and lemon with our variety
eight pack as you guys know jackie and i
are co-founders of spritz society canned
cocktails really the only beverage
you'll ever need period
period and a diet coke but
okay and diet coke and i guess like
water to live but whatever um we
launched with four flavors they were
popping off and then we just announced a
fifth one which is peach which is kind
of like taking over as the best one just
saying um and so you can add the newest
flavor peach to your cart then get the
variety pack which has all four flavors
two of each cans and you'll get the
complete spritz society experience and
of course we have a code a bigger and
better code than yesterday ready get
ready for labor day weekend use code ldw
as in labor day weekend 2-0 ldw20 ldw20
for 20 off all your orders of 85 or more
chars with code ldw20
for 20 off
great thank you so much it's pleasure
today's stories are in no particular
order so just do it that way you will uh
they're all i actually like what you did
with the stories bingo are you ready for
our first story very sad story that has
been developing throughout the last two
weeks but jaclyn hill's ex-husband john
passed away and she said his death is
the saddest weirdest thing i just want
to say like not to make light of but i
it sounded like the way you pronounced
it was that his last name was passed
away you said john passed away
jacqueline hill's husband passed away
yeah you said jacqueline hill's husband
john passed away oh sorry like i know
that's really inappropriate i didn't say
that but i just just like i didn't know
that was his last name oh no but it's
hill
that's why her name is jaclyn hill
jacqueline hill described her late
ex-husband john hill's death and her
grieving process as the quote saddest
weirdest thing given they had been
divorced for five years she said quote
i'm at the point of my grieving process
where i just have to trust it and see
what happens every day right now i'm
just kind of done sharing this with
millions of people and i just kind of
need some privacy on this subject
totally she said that although they had
not been romantically involved for years
she and the drummer remained closed she
said quote we still kept in touch and
talked
it's so much you guys trying to go
through it publicly it's just making it
so much harder for me
and do they have details in there about
how he passed
he i believe was struggling with
addiction uh the autopsy results will
take months um the cause of death has
been deferred pending for their testing
so i don't um like follow jaclyn hill
but um
a lot of people do and for a really long
time he was like a huge part of her
content so it's definitely weird to like
and then he wasn't you know because they
got divorced and like two people you
were
watching consistently like one of them
it is just cut out of the story
um so i think it's like
definitely challenging to grieve this
way because like so many people felt
like they knew him um and it's also they
weren't together right so then it's also
challenging to grieve someone you were
in love with but aren't anymore yeah and
someone who like at one point was
every minute of every day for you right
now and hasn't been for five years and
so she did a q a a little while ago like
maybe a couple of weeks and somebody had
asked about john and she was like you
know um
no one's really heard from him and i
think like when you're
dealing with someone who is struggling
with addiction that's like never
a good sign
so this is just like a really sad story
and one that's like difficult because so
many people like they feel entitled to
grieve him too and like want to grieve
with her but she just has to like
protect her peace yeah and she needs
like her own time and space yeah but
also i think people want updates from
her and it's like
this isn't either typical i think
grieving on social media is like
especially not like we talked about
olivia noon john when it's someone that
you know you know someone going through
a grief on social media
on social media about someone who
was also on social media with you at one
point and then not like there's so many
different layers it's very complicated
and her like navigating through it right
now i imagine is challenging and like
he's not really her family anymore so
she has to respect his family's privacy
how they want it to be handled
so it's like a really it's a weird
situation yeah and i will say i don't
know a ton about jaclyn hill but like
what i do know
about her peripherally just like she
comes up on my tick tock a lot and now i
think i actually follow her and then she
had like a lot of scandal with her
makeup line just everything i know about
her actually makes me really like her me
too um especially because i know she
went through like a lot of physical
changes online and people were so
[ __ ] mean to her um
and she like handled it all with like a
lot of grace which is like
couldn't be me um so i just really like
her even though i don't know like a ton
about her yeah no any time i like
watched her videos over the years i
really liked her i still use champagne
pop every single day i forgot that's her
wearing it right now even though it's
been discontinued and the one that i
have has lasted me years like great
[ __ ] product champagne pop was like
changed the beauty industry forever i'm
wearing it right now
with becca
and jacqueline and now becca cosmetics
is
there's been a few makeup companies that
like
bite beauty just went really yeah
but i mean how can how can they not yeah
becca you're right i remember we did a
story in our old pink studio about it no
no in the
windows oh did was it the windows i
believe well with all these new like
there's a new makeup company popping off
every single day and like there's really
it's not like podcasting there's not
enough space my face is only so big to
wear so many sephora is only so big
there can only be so many little you
know it's finite yeah it's not infinite
there are only so many departments yeah
so and then when it doesn't happen more
yeah when you go up against like the
celebrities every influencer jaclyn and
now jacqueline cosmetics like after
their first initial launch with the
hairs on the lipstick they got together
i see people reviewing her products all
the time and it apparently is very
popular so there's just really not
enough space i'm surprised it's just
here's not enough space because there's
not enough face
you're with the slogans today
slogomania slogio sluggio
so i'm wishing jacqueline the best i
really like her yes me too and i hope
that she like finds peace and is able to
navigate it on social media and take the
space on her own that she needs whatever
she needs you know
our next story is a kind of crazy beef
between amandla stenberg and a film
critic this is so weird i saw it on tick
tock and i was like what the [ __ ] is
going on okay so amanda stenberg uh is
slamming a film critic over the bodies
bodies bodies review and alleged dms i'm
gonna take it from the top because i i
read it and there's a lot here
a film critic shared a screenshot
appearing to show a sternly worded
message from actress amandla stenberg
following a recent review of her film
bodies bodies bodies after new york
times writer lena wilson reviewed
amandla's latest on-screen venture a24's
horror film helmed by 20 somethings her
instagram dms were seemingly hit with a
message from the star herself who plays
sophie
lena wilson's review of the film which
also stars maria bakalova lee pace
rachel sennett and pete davidson was
somewhat negative and it seems as though
amandla had some choice words for the
writer
the
uh woman wrote in her review the only
thing that really sets bodies bodies
bodies apart is its place in the a24
height machine where it doubles as a 95
minute advertisement for cleavage and
charlie xcx latest special
so then the critic shared a screenshot
of her dms with allegedly a message from
amandla saying quote maybe if you had
gotten your eyes off my tits you could
have watched the movie
then the critic tweeted alongside the
screenshot saying do you think she
instagram dm'd allison wilmore justin
chang and anthony lang lane like this or
dot dot dot in a follow-up tweet uh the
critic claimed that amandla's dm was
somewhat homophobic she said quote
always weird when the homophobia is
coming from inside the house but this is
something
i don't know if so then amandla has
responded oh
uh
she
so amanda's comment generated backlash
uh after it was posted to twitter by the
critic but the actor said in her own
instagram video that she was just trying
to be funny with her message she said
quote i'm receiving a lot of commentary
on the internet for being a very naughty
girl and for sending a dm that i thought
was hilarious there's a film critic and
her name is lena wilson she described
body body bodies bodies bodies as a 95
minute advertisement for cleavage which
i thought was hilarious i'm proud that a
piece of work i was a part of was
described as such in such a renowned
publication i thought it was hilarious i
thought because lena is gay and i'm also
gay as gay people we would both find
this comment funny
is amandla gaslighting us like yes
yes i was also curious to know what lena
would say to such a statement lena
decided to publish it and also says that
i am homophobic for saying that
okay wait i did not see that amandala
had responded um and her response is
so confusing to me
yeah um because
the whole thing is like first of all the
first like who cares nobody reads the
movie no not even that but like part of
putting out movies is getting reviewed
by film critics it's not like
and then and this is what the critic was
saying it's like plenty of people
reviewed this movie and you only dm'd me
right also to like take a public review
and then like dm someone personally is
weird like she could have posted that
right like so
the whole the whole exchange is weird
and then the critic shared you know
amandla's message and i think then she
like it seemed like amanda was trying to
shame the critic the critic then shane
demandla amanda's back to shaming the
critic and it's like we're all losing
wait okay my take on the story like was
so different before i saw that
she had responded and her response is
giving like it's gaslighting what are
you guys talking about i was being funny
like
um i do think like
amandla's dm to her
i don't necessarily think it was
homophobic but impact versus intent like
maybe the writer felt it was homophobic
but i don't think that's like also what
the writer was trying to say is like she
was the only like lesbian critic who got
a message from amanda that's why when
she said like why did you dm all these
other people yes
oh okay okay okay okay that's fair
that's fair um it just seems like
this is a great press for the movie so
it's a win-win um i agree this is not a
mandalas first movie she's been acting
since she was in hunger games when she
was like eight um and you're supposed to
be immune to this stuff and not everyone
is and and that's fine um
this is like i'm sure her pr team woke
up in a tizzy because honestly it
doesn't make her look great like
privately messaging one critic like who
cares you're a movie star like go to a
red carpet go be fabulous who cares
about some writer
um about some writer girl
and i don't know i can't really i don't
know whose side i'm on because part of
me is like
you know in this climate i don't i think
maybe this new york times writer could
see how like maybe that wasn't the most
appropriate thing to say like this movie
is a 95 minute you know uh advertising
advertisement for cleavage but when i
read the critics like take she was
basically saying that
nothing about amandla's cleavage but
more so how a24 is known for exploiting
young girls and it was a statement on
that as opposed to like a mandala being
promiscuous right but then amandla said
in this second statement she said it's
quite surprising the amount of
commentary i receive on my boobs i wrote
this tank top in this movie because me
and the costume designer felt it fit the
character well i do get tired of people
talking about my chest there seems to be
a lot of unwarranted conversation about
my chest well now here's even more
unwarranted conversation about your
chest but uh anyways what i'm just
wanting to point out is that she wrote
the tank top into the movie and i i feel
like it's the kind of movie where
they're wearing the same outfit the
whole time right like it's a horror
movie it takes place in one night and so
it's 95 minutes of everyone in the same
outfit and she chose this tank top oh
that can be frustrating for a movie
watcher like change your clothes
someone who like loves costume design
right right i mean this doesn't make me
want to see the movie more or less i
hadn't even heard about it
but david citizen it's like maybe i will
all in all i don't really have a take
here it sounds like a little bit of you
know loser and loser crime yeah like
everyone's coming out of this a loser
and i
i really don't
see anyone being particularly right or
particularly wrong amanda is definitely
taking the l i think a little bit more
because she it's like this big fancy
movie star attacking this like little
innocent writer um but again like i just
don't care yeah she ended her statement
with lena i thought your review was
hilarious i thought my dm oh my god the
gaslighting
i thought my dm was funny i did not mean
to harass you i do not wish you any harm
you're allowed to have criticism on my
work and i'm allowed to have my
criticisms of your work i wish you the
best so was it criticism of her work or
was it funny i just think maybe it was a
joke for amandla but like i don't think
they've ever met before
you know when you're sliding in with a
meanie joke and like making fun of
someone's work like it's very easy to be
misinterpreted no for sure especially
when there's a power dynamic like this
is a big movie star
with a like a writer who
she's never met
yeah like you're not going to
immediately think this big movie star
after you just wrote a bad critique of
her movie is sending you a message
that's in a joking manner you would
probably think of it more as like in a
mean manner yeah i could see that this
like she meant it as a joke like i could
believe that but i also could imagine
receiving it and be like
yikes yeah um so yeah i don't know i
just think nothing good comes out of
like reading reviews honestly like if i
was an actor i would never read reviews
it's the same way like a lot of
influencers like go out of there i never
to check like those threads about them
like it's not good you got to protect
your piece
you did your best in this role and
that's the best you could have done yeah
just doing our best but here's some
press for the movie that i personally
hadn't heard of before right so that's
good and who knew a24 was like this
controversial production company do you
know what it was yeah like i've seen
their
you know before movies and before
trailers come out it's always like
searchlight you know they they'll show
like the logos and i've seen a24 like a
million times i think it's just like
popular but i guess they have this
reputation who knew
okay but like they didn't choose the
tank top that's so true she said that
she did that's true so i guess they're
not exploiting women young women in this
scenario
in this one yeah
okay are you ready for our next story
some things around just to keep it light
kylie jenner reveals she almost had this
k name
so kylie shared on tik tok she did a
trend that um
people are sharing like my name is blank
but i was almost named blank right so
it's my name is kylie but it was almost
kennedy which i find so surprising
because it's so similar to kendall
and true and they call kendall kenny
true maybe at the end of the day that's
why it wasn't but i i didn't even think
of that i was just thinking okay so what
if it was kennedy cosmetics kennedy
jenner and i think her life would be the
exact same thing i don't think it would
i think it would have been so cute and
it wouldn't have changed anything
kennedy is a really cute name of course
my mind goes to kennedy armstrong taylor
armstrong's daughter because it's really
the only kennedy i know you know it
doesn't go to the kennedys not as a
first name now oh kennedy like as a
first name is literally taylor
armstrong's daughter who had a 60 000
birthday party yeah um
and that's i didn't i didn't think about
like what all the the brands would be
called kennedy skin no there's something
about kylie being two syllables and then
it was just a great name for kai lighter
kai liner i don't know what you could
have done with kennedy yeah
it's true so um in an episode in the
season finale of kardashians uh
kim and was talking to chris about like
naming the girls that kendall was almost
called juliet
and then uh they talked about how she
chose kylie she said
chris said quote we just kept saying
kendall and sophia kendall and jane you
know trying to think what what with
kendall oh that's cute it was kendall
and you know kelly then when we got to
kendall and kylie we went that's it
kendall and kylie have to go together oh
but i okay so i guess i was surprised
that they would even entertain the name
because it's so similar to kendall but
now it's like that's exactly why they
entertained it yeah kendall and kennedy
that's cute they were twins yeah sisters
but you know i feel like twins
especially when they're younger like go
through some sort of identity crisis of
like having their own independence and
if your name is literally one letter
different that makes that journey that
much harder for sure and i used to feel
like having twins was you know not
like i wouldn't have wanted to have
twins but now like having like being a
mom and being pregnant like it sounds
like a dream oh my god so much fun if
their names have to be work together
it's so much fun saves you five years of
your life i would like to have
quintuplets the first time yeah okay
three years the parent perspective like
i also think like i can now see it as a
sibling like if we were twin like and i
just think that parents have to go out
of their way to make sure like the kids
have their own thing going on
but i think like it could be grand slam
for everyone i completely agree and then
you have like a built-in best friend
yeah and of course there i think there's
some years in puberty where you go
through a rough patch like hating your
twin because it's like i just want my
own life and then the older you get you
are so appreciative that you've had this
like partner through your whole life
especially if you're watching like three
identical strangers just like how
biologically connected twins are
triplets like it's just everything no i
agree i used to be like oh my god
everything i used to think like being a
twin was like the worst thing like no i
want to be my own person i would hate to
be like grouped up no i think there's so
many benefits i think literally like
being born with a best friend of course
siblings are always best well they
should ideally but like you're in the
room with someone you're in the crib
with someone that warms i really three
identical strangers really changed my
perspective on it too like how you know
just
biologically how like impactful it is
and but i do think when it comes to
twins as you grow up there's definitely
some
you know um interesting scenarios that
you get get yourself in like i always
think like and i think i asked lauren
lane this because chris lane has an
identical twin i'm like do you ever like
see the twin be like hot because
logically you think this person's
attractive so an identical twin
logically could go for the same for a
sibling that looks alike yeah but like
looks alike is different than identical
we all know have you seen chris lane's
twin yeah but like i think there's
always like a little bit of difference
with twins so if like a freak if you
have the one that you that like you love
and you one thing you'll always think of
like the other one is like the one
that's a little different yeah i guess
that's true that's true
you know and then you could marry other
twins and have biologically siblings yes
goals
yeah no i think twins are great um i
could have been good with kennedy jenner
yeah but i'm glad we got kylie she's
such a kylie and of course she is
because that's her name and you bloom
where you planted
but um
kylie was the move do you know what your
name almost was no i didn't have one of
those you did i have a couple yeah
alexis alexis a little bit alexis could
you guys see it claudia
alexis and claude i could see you being
an alexis no
like i could see your face like it's not
that far off is what i'm saying but like
you're jackie o i'm jackie oh yeah and
then also almost victoria which i think
i wouldn't have liked until last year
now that i'm obsessed with victoria i
love the name but i think um it would
have taken me a while to come to that i
don't think i
would like no no margo was almost grace
and i don't think me and olivia had
backup backups i don't think so either
what was rolled almost nothing he was
like always rolled right no um he was
almost wolf
he was almost wolf thank god not one
he's not a wolf and two kylie jean [ __ ]
like how embarrassing would that be oh
my god you would have had to been like
no i was kidding i would have had to
like love the name so much that like it
wasn't about kylie she just like threw
it out there and i actually really do
like the name just not for me like in
any way shape or form but like for
another go yeah
for mr blitzer from history the only
person i know named and uh tammy
uh
that influencer has a kid named wolf oh
the one who was friends with kylie and
then thought that kylie stole her name
yeah she's the one who like fainted at
kylie's birthday party right and was
never invited to another gala ever again
yeah speaking of galas did you see i
thought this was such an interesting
branding move the kardashians like threw
an event like last night or the night
before and it was an 818 investor dinner
slash meeting so everyone who was there
was an investor in 818 and of course it
was kylie kendall everyone
orlando blue i saw him i saw him talking
to him jennifer meyer jewelry she was an
investor she showed up which i thought
was like such a random really good for
her like get your coin um i thought that
was like a cool
way to market the brand a little bit
with all the celebrities i just thought
i thought that was actually really smart
and different yeah also they came out
with the 818 reserve bottle i was
watching a video of it on chris's
instagram it looks so premium i actually
wanted to get it for you i thought
seriously i saw it and i thought it was
a sculpture of a pair of tits at first
it's very beautiful it's sculpted like
it's different yeah i think i mean i
don't drink tequila but
like it's a nice looking bottle
i wonder how 818 is doing yeah
they work it hard they work it hard and
um
because of kendall and because they had
a ton of money behind it they were able
to like launch immediately and get into
every store in every state which is a
liquor brand you have to go state by
state it goes slow um
but getting in the stores is one thing
are people buying it in the stores i
don't know i'm curious yeah because
there's a lot of hype for it i've tried
it and i love the kardashians and i love
tequila i won't go out of tequila is
very personal more personal than comedy
so to get someone to switch their like
go-to brand is really difficult what but
like if you're at a party and all they
have is 8-1-8 like are you
happy sad and different um
i'm not happy but i'm not sad i was just
like oh i'll drink it but like i wish my
brand was here what's your brand custom
egos everyone has like a brand they feel
safe with yeah and that takes time and
it takes like industry like respect you
know everyone's like awesome he goes
custom english and i tried it i was like
oh well if everyone loves it and it's
good i love it you know
so i think those things take time got it
but the branding is on fleek
yeah no it really is and they do cute
events and
though wait you saw for kylie's birthday
they all went on a boat and that video
went viral of kim was like i want a shot
which was crazy because kim never drinks
then she took a shot and spit it out and
she was like that's literally disgusting
she's going through a breakup so she's
taking shots and so everyone was like
eight one eight eight one eight and then
kim was like she tweeted i wish it was
eight one eight but like how was it not
eight one eight you know i don't know
was kendall there
i don't think so i think maybe she was
actually but
chloe wasn't and courtney wasn't but
that's like so them everywhere they go
they have all of their things i know but
like to be in a yacht like
that's a lot of tequila to have to ship
and it's like just cargo and it's like
it's it's possible that it wasn't i just
feel like it was and i don't think
that's a statement on 8-1-8 if you don't
drink tequila no matter the best is
disgusting like yeah it's not coffee
it's gross like yeah so even if you're
drinking the best tequila in the world
if you're not someone who drinks you're
going to think be like it's gasoline so
i don't think it's an indictment on
eight one eight as a brand i think they
all drink eight one eight you know a lot
of the time but i think kylie like
drinks 42 yeah because the thing
tequila is more personal than comedy but
i think like just because she drinks 42
like doesn't mean she dislikes eight one
eight like you can drink both obviously
you know literally but everyone has like
a brand that they gravitate towards yeah
and that's on the truth mm-hmm
are you ready for our next story which
is the one that i swapped out for the j
shetty and i think you're gonna really
appreciate it okay because it's friday
which means we're going down memory lane
and talking about hannah montana
the hannah montana casting director
reveals which two stars almost wore the
blonde wig over miley huh
oh i think i've heard this because she
was on tick tock it's a ticking super
short show girl
who's that the girl from cheaper by the
dozen who's like you know tomboy stoner
yes nope that's not what she said
so after let me keep guessing okay but
ashley tisdale no
okay tick tock video went viral claiming
that spanish mexican singer belinda was
almost snagged for the role the actual
casting director lisa london set the
record straight and posted one of her
own videos on wednesday to explain that
this wasn't the case she said quote i'm
actually the original casting director
on hannah montana and i discovered miley
cyrus i wanted to let everyone know that
belinda who is lovely by the way was
never in the top three for the role of
hannah maybe allison soner was in the
tops but this is top three okay
miley cyrus mm-hmm
taylor momsen
oh my god jenny from brooklyn
and daniela monet who wound up being on
victorious oh you know it's so
interesting how like
and i feel like this is
so
uh relevant because of janet mccurdy's
book
like the child acting world is actually
really small i imagine there's not like
a million kids clamoring to get
like
they
there's just like the same couple of
kids who who were there at the same time
yeah and they all in one way or another
eventually did something but this was a
network test out of over 1200 girls
those were the top three the name chloe
also was supposed to be the name for um
the main character before miley was
supposed to be chloe stewart but then
they changed it to miley stewart chloe
stewart is cute chloe stewart is cute
but i think there was a lot of name
first of all miley's an iconic name but
i remember reading like a while ago
there was already a lot of names
happening because you had chloe then you
have miley cyrus and you have hannah
montana so they sort of
i thought you sit down that was like a
thing they did sometimes like raven
that's so raven raven simone ravenna
really can make something truly iconic
but it also makes the actor or actress
it makes it really hard for them to
break out from
that uh
being that person i actually don't agree
i think that it gives them like
star power to another level like it
makes their career worse bigger and
longer but i think for hannah like
because she was able to
differentiate between hannah and miley
it was okay but like if hillary duff if
her name had been lizzie
it would have been even harder for her
maybe yeah
but i also think that's just a byproduct
of being a child star like you're going
to be that transition is hard no matter
when and where it comes you're stunted
as that person people are always going
to assume so if they're going to assume
like jeanette mccready was saying like
people just used to be like sam sam sam
and she was she hated being famous so
much she's like if people didn't even
know my real name i would not take a
photo with them but with miley it's like
they already did you know yeah exactly
it just makes it more infused you're you
are that person but it could
set you up for bigger success and then
it also just created the name miley like
it was like a popular kid's name
because of her no one had heard that
name before yeah i obviously think they
made the right choice like there's no
one who could there was no one like
miley also i think those other two girls
would have really been the wrong choice
one because taylor momsen obviously we
saw her grow up she would not have
wanted to be a disney star and she would
have rebelled in every which way like
you thought miley smoking salvia was bad
like yeah just wait till you see what
jenny humphries came out that's true
actually she went through a tough
transition she did not want to be a role
model yeah
and then daniella monet like was great
being victorious sister
but she i she wouldn't have been my
hannah yeah no i don't think she had
like at the time the star power to carry
an entire show franchise tour merch
everything that comes along with it and
then with miley we also got her dad
who's literally one of the best
characters yeah and it just made the
whole thing like a really cool and
relevant culture
it was really nepotism at its finest
like miley obviously had a leg up on the
other two girls because she was bringing
her dad and because she was a famous kid
like but i think that it it worked it
was perfection it was the perfect recipe
no one could have done it like mine and
also it's like sure you know she does
the singing she has the dab but like her
comedic timing was so perfect
she was amazing but i think she probably
got to the top of those 1200 kids
because of her dad and that's where i
feel like the show wouldn't have been
the same without the nepotism i think it
was an important it was the salt it was
a pinch of you know yeah two more
important ingredient an important
ingredient
no final story yeah you put the um ipad
down yes sorry it was just giving fifth
and final energy it was because like i
love to wrap up with miley whoa
yeah
that's how we should transition between
stories we should add a button you know
how we have the crunch yes we need and
we can have there's eight buttons we can
program they could all be different oh
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah love love our fifth and final story
is a little financial news i know you
guys will love and trust when we deliver
financials
what did you say you bloom where you
planted oh you bloom where you're
planted i am you bloom or you're
mcplanted or it could be a directive
bloom where you're planted [ __ ] [ __ ]
love love i love throwing a [ __ ] at the
end of anything you do
our physical story some financial news
just not really news because that would
be really depressing but it's more of a
success story success story it's good
news it's good financial news for this
college student who made 110 million
dollars trading shares of bed bath and
beyond
a 20 year old college student made 110
million dollars by selling his stake in
retailer bed bath and beyond after the
company's stock price searched over a
one-month period this summer an echo of
last year's meme stock boom jake freeman
who was studying applied mathematics did
you wish economics bill friedman
f-r-e-e-m-m-a-n
i don't know freedman is for sure
freeman i don't know no
um he's studying those things at us
those things like i don't need to say it
again it was a mouthful we were
literally talking about this yesterday
like if your major comes up in like
conversation as an adult and like it
really doesn't unless you make 110
million dollars or you're currently
still a student yeah uh
he bought five million shares in bed
bath and beyond in july at just under
five dollars and fifty cents a share he
owned around sixty six percent of the
company as a result of his investment on
tuesday the stock price soared so
soared to more than 27 a share
regulatory filings reviewed by financial
times showed that he sold more than 130
million dollars worth of stock using his
td ameritrade and interactive brokers
accounts but not on the computer like i
thought wait okay so if he bought five
million shares at five dollars a share
how much money is that a lot of money so
he had a lot of money to start how
maybe he's been trading like for a long
time so
because i thought it was like you know
he took a hundred dollars right no no it
wasn't it wasn't not to be rude it makes
it like a little less impressive you
bought how many shares five million
that's what you said five million
times five twenty five million dollars
twenty-five million dollars he was
playing around with
i mean if like if this is what he does
for fun like maybe i'm
why would he still be in college if he
had 25 million dollars he has been
investing alongside his uncle who was a
former pharmaceutical executive so maybe
he was giving him the money to play with
to his like genius nephew who's studying
applied mathematics you know i chose
this as a success story but now it's
turning into an investigation how does a
college kid have access to 25 million
dollars he's investing alongside his
uncle yeah uncle
um i'm
sorry he said that the initial 25
million dollar stake that he bought in
the company was made possible by raising
money from friends and family so he must
have really believed in this like i
thought they're making it seem like it
was like oh i'm surprised i made this
much money what if your nephew okay like
you don't have a nephew so like okay
yeah
no what if like in 10 years michaela's
like coming to all of us pitching um i
need seed money i'm i have this good
feeling about this internet stock um
five million dollars we'll do the trick
it depends what i know about her up
until this point is she like a kid
genius is she studying applied
mathematics and i've seen her do
incredible things along the way it's not
like she just like woke up one day it's
like i think i'll be an investor today
yeah yeah
that's nice it's nice to have i believe
in kayla it's the question nice to have
friends in the dancer yes nice to have
friends and family who like
even if it's like a great idea have
access to 25 million dollars to like put
together into some sort of seed round
yeah but it's not a seed round it's just
i don't know wondering if well so
everyone got like a great roi but did he
put in any of his own money or did he
make 110 million for other people uh
well the investor just like if this were
you know an investment house like they
get a cut yeah
curious i wonder if he has a girlfriend
he does now
he will he will soon we'll get snatcher
over there
yeah so happy for him happy for him
it's nice i love love love 100 million
dollars like i think that's really never
a bad thing really gorgeous yeah of
course i think you should get something
give him to charity
um after he pays back all of his maybe
he'll run off with it we'll have
ourselves like a made off situation
we'll keep you posted for sure on the
college kid
with 100 yeah we were talking about
majors and like what is an embarrassing
major and what is respectable then it
turns out margo's is embarrassing margot
has a really embarrassing major i didn't
i honestly didn't know that about her
sociology
big yikes yikes mine's median
communications which isn't great but
given the work that i do i think it
makes it fine it looks like this has
always been your dream and you have
lived a successful dream and then i
bloomed where i was planted and my major
is history which if you know anything
about me it shows that she studied what
she loved yeah i think stuttering
studying history or english is like so
standard you know it doesn't blink makes
it respectable it's not like oh applied
mathematics right but it's okay
mathematics political science maybe you
learned some interesting stuff economics
those are all very respectful maybe you
like learn some facts yeah
and read some good books yeah
then there are the ones that are that
are just like it's it's giving low gpa
you know which by the way i had a low
gpa so i'm not being like no but at
least like you're able to cover a lot of
people have a low gpa but it's not what
something you lead with no end like
it's so isn't particularly high it's so
important to stress how like having a
high gpa means literally nothing about
you in the real world like
i am i'm a mogul and at one point i was
put on academic probation like
who wasn't no a lot of people no i
really was you know you get academic
probation when your gpa is below 2.0
i had gotten enough of the one i spoke
about earlier it just took you down took
me way down especially when my grades
weren't that great like the other
classes were just like b's i know but
like when you get an f you have to take
the class over or um lose the credits
this is the credit i actually once got a
d
which is worse because it just sat there
and it brought the whole ship down well
i never retook the class so i had the f
and i lost the four credits but as i've
previously stated i was taking vocal
lessons
right like you were one step further to
graduation but i mean
yeah yeah yeah and it's not like i was
trying to go to grad school so right i
was taking vocal lessons for two credits
every semester so i was always like in
the surplus when it came to credits so
the four credits like i just like you
could not pay me to take that [ __ ]
class again like i i didn't even care
about the f honestly
so yeah having like a high gpa like good
for you nobody cares go get a job here's
the thing c's get degrees c's get
degrees and i just f's and d's don't
i'll remember i'll never forget going to
my five year high school reunion and
like chatting with some of the kids in
my high school who are like the smartest
like most promising
and i was like what are you guys up to
and they were like oh you know i just
traveled um looking for a job and then
someone else was like yeah no i think
i'm going to fashion marketing and i was
like but you had all the promise you're
supposed to be like at goldman sachs
yeah so having a high gpa just means
nothing honestly having street smarts
it's not about what you do with it it's
about what you do with everything is all
about what you do it's about having
charisma it's about having so many other
things and like being able to crunch
numbers not having nerve
charisma uniqueness nerve and talent no
i'm not even kidding i mean putting
yourself out there no totally taking
risks and embarrassing yourself and
honestly i feel like maybe being really
academically smart puts you at a
disadvantage because like you feel like
that's that's the one and only way you
need to succeed in order to move forward
in your life but there's so many other
things involved with getting a job it's
like it's about let's say you're you're
auditioning or interviewing for a job
and there's multiple candidates and
you're like the one who's really good
with the numbers and really smart and
has the highest gpa but then there's
someone else who's you know a great
teamworker because he's very charismatic
and outgoing and so if you're so focused
on just like getting 100 on every test
you're not learning other skills in
school which are really just as
important being social being outgoing
being helpful all these different things
yeah so
just know if you get a c it's fine but
that's why you should like go for a job
that really only cares about the numbers
and doesn't care about how you work with
the other data scientists right like
engineer no i'm not engineering i'm like
what was that book i just read love
hypothesis she's like a scientist yeah
yeah like it doesn't matter like just so
what is your data just do the job right
accountant i don't need an accountant
with a great personality okay yeah i
just need an accountant who can crunch
numbers and knows the law and knows the
loopholes yeah i didn't say that irs i
did not say that oh yeah you don't want
to start with them no um but if they do
start with me i will finish them no i
don't know
it's that's my mission in life i'm
taking down the irs no i'm totally
kidding they're more powerful than ever
don't come for me it's so true
okay well that's our show that is our
show it's officially the weekend for us
well not really but it's officially the
weekend so just throw that laptop out
the window and go party
and monday we're back remote i miss you
so much
i miss you more when do you think you'll
come back i don't know she doesn't have
plans to when's your next show when are
you going on alabama so that's why i'm
going home so i'm coming home on sunday
i have a show
thursday in red bank there's very few
tickets left so new jersey peeps girls
no job.com tour get how theo is sleeping
snoring sleeping so good but he's like
hanging off the chair i think both the
boys are snoring are we that boring no
we're that peaceful like it's it's
the best voice it's their mother's voice
like
so i don't know because then then i have
like shows i'm in portland seattle i
think i have to go to la for work then i
have um long island so
it might be like october before i'm back
honestly okay so i'm gonna try to get to
new york in september yeah try and come
for my long island show
oh that would be fun yeah and like once
i'm weaned i'm going to go to dr geezy
for some botox i'm so [ __ ] excited
it's very exciting but i'm a few weeks
away i want to we've got big things all
of us have goals and dreams and i hope
to accomplish them thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the monday morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio buying
radio ken's box all the places wherever
you listen to the podcast find us the
morning shows leave a five-star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
amazing weekend and we'll see you on
monday goodbye